sí
[Música]
a compartir con ustedes el tema de kobe
desde una perspectiva feminista
el día internacional de las mujeres este
año fue histórico en méxico decenas de
mujeres salimos a las calles las tomamos
y el día siguiente desaparecimos de las
calles
cada una a nuestra manera el 8 y el 9 de
marzo de 2020 méxico visibilizó y las
mujeres mexicanas visibilizamos la
violencia feminicida y la estructura que
la sostiene buscando generar un debate
extendido exigiendo pronunciamiento y
compromiso de todos los actores claves
para acabar con esta pandemia
géminis
pero mientras nosotras marchábamos en
méjico el mundo estaba ya comenzando a
paralizarse por un virus que ha cobrado
más de 60 mil vidas confinando personas
y familias en sus hogares llamándolos ya
de por sí frágiles sistemas de salud en
el mundo en esta situación inédita
las niñas adolescentes y mujeres nos
encontramos entre la espada y la pared
de dos crisis de salud pública la
pandemia y la violencia de género en un
país donde el machismo es patrimonio
nacional
ante la rápida propagación de sars v2
este nuevo virus que
conmocionado al mundo las medidas de
distanciamiento pues resultan
fundamentales
paradójicamente además de que el quédate
en casa se confronta con distintas
realidades socioeconómicas el
aislamiento y confinamiento preocupa
mucho en un país donde la violencia
doméstica es la más incidente de las
violencias de las mujeres y gran parte
de los temas feminicidios son
perpetrados en contextos familiares de
pareja o de amistad en una pandemia
estas situaciones pueden exacerbarse por
un lado el estrés y la incertidumbre
económica son disparadores por el otro
el confinamiento aleja las mujeres de
sus redes de apoyo
es imperante implementar programas para
atender la problemática en el nuevo
contexto cómo puedo pedir ayuda hacer
convivencia obligada con mi agresor por
ejemplo las aplicaciones móviles podrían
ser soluciones aunque con limitaciones
sabemos que se pueden habilitar para
funcionar como botones de pánico pero es
que todas las mujeres en méjico tenemos
acceso a una aplicación móvil o incluso
en internet
otra consecuencia del confinamiento es
que se acentúa la desigualdad en la
repetición de las labores no remuneradas
de cuidado basada siempre en
estereotipos machistas está normalizada
está que hasta autoridades en nuestro
país han dudado en afirmar que las
mujeres en casa podrían estar pendientes
de la salud de las personas mayores
explicando que los varones suelen ser
más desprendidos
en la cuarentena la mayoría de las
mujeres serán responsables de tareas
domésticas incrementadas cuidado de las
infancias incluyendo el apoyo en su
educación dado el cierre de las escuelas
la atención a familiares con alguna
discapacidad física o mental cuidado de
personas ancianas y en su caso atención
a las mismas personas que se enfermaran
de kobe 19 algunas mujeres tendrán que
lidiar también con la carga de trabajo
profesional considerando que de por sí
viven mayor precariedad laboral y
perciben salarios menores todo esto
genera situaciones de agobio cansancio
crónico y desgaste mental mismas que
pueden afectar de manera permanente la
salud emocional física y mental de
nosotras además las corrientes bioéticas
tradicionales en este momento tienden a
enfocarse en valores individualistas
como la autonomía individual ignorando
otro tipo de principios éticos y
bioéticos que hoy necesitamos como son
la solidaridad la compasión y valores
comunitarios en pensar que nuestras
acciones individuales pueden tener una
aceptación a personas en situación de
vulnerabilidad y por tanto es pensar
desde la ética comunitaria en estos
tiempos de pando
es importante resaltar también que las
mujeres conforman el mayor número de
profesionales de atención a la salud y
además son mayoritarias en otros empleos
con gran exposición al contagio por
ejemplo las empleadas empleadas de la
limpieza doméstica las cajeras en
supermercados y farmacias sin embargo
más allá del riesgo de contraer con
1.019 el derecho a la salud de las
mujeres está comprometido durante esta
pandemia por ejemplo ante esta
emergencia sanitaria algunos medios de
comunicación en méxico han hecho
declaraciones irresponsables e inexactas
sobre la autoridad de algunos fármacos
como la hidroxi cloroquina sin
considerar que muchos de estos fármacos
son esenciales para preservar la vida de
miles de mujeres quienes son más
propensas según la evidencia científica
a desarrollar enfermedades crónicas como
la artritis reumatoide o lupus
y estas personas estas mujeres forman ya
parte de un grupo de riesgo ante el
comité civil
por otra parte también es importante
hacer sentido de que las mujeres
representan el 70 por ciento de quienes
conforman el profesional de la salud de
acuerdo con la organización mundial de
la salud es decir 70 por ciento de
enfermeras y médicas en todos los
sistemas de salud en el mundo son
mujeres es así como creo que en las
conferencias de prensa de nuestro país y
en todos los países deberían de estar
más presentes aquellas mujeres que están
en puestos claves de enfrentamiento de
la pandemia porque son un ejemplo a
seguir y sirvan también de roles de
modelos de muchas mujeres para saber que
pueden llegar a posiciones de liderazgo
de la profesión en la que se desempeña
son nuestras heroínas sin embargo
tristemente nos sorprenden pero es
altamente ilustrativo lo que sucede en
nuestro país la mayoría de las personas
presentes en las conferencias de prensa
sobre esta pandemia son hombres expertos
y esto se puede explicar porque la
mayoría de los puestos de directivos de
los institutos nacionales en nuestro
país y de la secretaría de salud son
ocupados por hombres de qué sirve que
sean mayoría de las heroínas del sector
salud
si siguen siendo subsumidas por la
heteronormatividad patriarcal en el
ámbito médico el colmo es de que incluso
el lenguaje que se utiliza es jerárquico
y basado en estereotipos sexuales cuando
se habla de las personas trabajadoras
del servicio del sector salud por
ejemplo constantemente se habla de
médicos
y enfermeras lo cual constituye a
exponer la estructura de poder existente
dominante es decir siempre representando
al personal médico desde lo masculino y
al personal de la enfermería desde lo
femenino
el destino prioritario de recursos y
personal médico para atender esta crisis
puede también afectar la salud sexual y
reproductiva de las mujeres en este país
con altas tasas de violencia no
solamente en las calles sino también
gineco-obstetras por ejemplo hace apenas
un par de días se han definido
protocolos especiales para la atención
de mujeres embarazadas protegiendo las
también de contagian del joven sin
embargo nada se ha dicho de los
servicios de emergencia a mujeres
víctimas de violencia sexual como medios
seguros para interrumpir un embarazo
producto de una violación la misma
preocupación existe sobre la
disponibilidad de servicios no
aplazables para terminar una gestación
cuando existe una causal permitida por
la ley y es en el caso de la ciudad de
mexico en oaxaca y otros estados es
decir interrumpir también un embarazo no
decir
el derecho a la salud está vinculado al
derecho a la vida desarrollo de la
personalidad dignidad humana libertad
sexual y reproductiva constituyendo
derechos humanos que no pueden ser
desbaratados por ninguna medida
excepcional la pandemia arrom ha logrado
resaltar y exacerbar desigualdades y
fallas a distintos niveles aunque el 8
de marzo parece otra vida las exigencias
son vigentes ahora más que nunca estos
temas sobre acceso a la salud justicia y
vida libre de violencia a las mujeres no
deben quedar de lado sino que deben
asumirse como parte fundamental de
cualquier plan de mitigación todas
estamos preocupadas por la pandemia pero
no olvidemos que la violencia machista
es el más fulminante mal en contra de
nuestras vidas
e internet en estos días juega un papel
clave en el seguimiento no solamente en
el control de la pandemia sino también
en combatir la persistente violencia de
género en nuestro país de manera
importante el confinamiento
distanciamiento social al ser observado
esta violencia que sobre ser sufre en
los hogares más aún donde los hogares
comparten con el prd con el perpetrador
de la violencia en espacios de 4 x 5
metros cuadrados indudablemente las
aplicaciones móviles y el acceso a
internet podrían ser herramientas
adecuadas como se señaló antes para
garantizar apoyo psicológico y así
evitar no solamente la violencia física
sino los potenciales suicidios
medidas como éstas han sido
implementarse en otros países de américa
latina como es el caso de argentina por
ejemplo el desarrollo de una aplicación
gratuita por parte del ministerio de las
mujeres géneros y diversidades ha sido
un recurso complementario de información
y aquellas mujeres que no tienen acceso
a internet pueden llamar a otra amiga oa
un familiar para que puedan hacer una
llamada o mensaje mediante esta
aplicación y directamente ayudar a la
mujer que está en riesgo
sin embargo pues es importante recordar
que nuestro país
no se tiene en muchos casos el acceso al
internet y es importante recordar que
entonces este tema de violencia de
género se tiene que abordar desde la
intersección alidad es decir reconocer
los factores socioeconómicos como un
obstáculo incluso para acceder a un
teléfono móvil ya no se diga de
cualquier otra tecnología por lo tanto
los esfuerzos deben estar dirigidos en
proporción a acceso en internet y
móviles para mujeres en situación de
pobreza o indígenas por ejemplo
y finalmente la falta de elementos de
seguridad para los profesionales de la
salud particularmente nuestras
enfermeras nuestras heroínas han sido
atacadas no solamente por el maldito
corazón descorazonado por enemigos sino
también por la sociedad desinformada
quien las ha atacado con una crueldad no
vista en otro país una situación de
vergüenza nacional ningún gobierno
deberá considerar estas situaciones como
secundarias por las mujeres en méjico
estoy segura de que nunca olvidaremos ni
perdonaremos y exigiremos siempre
justicia para todas muchas gracias